[Musique]
très difficilement parce que le premier
confinement est tombé sur la tête de
tout le monde et a surpris énormément de
personnes avec les contraintes de faire
l'école à la maison de faire l'école sur
différents niveaux de s'organiser de
pouvoir gérer la maison et toutes les
activités des enfants qui s'est arrêté
donc c'était très compliqué l'école à la
maison des choses qu'aucun ils sont pas
habitués surtout quand on a des familles
qui sont pas par exemple qui ont des
situations d'illettrisme des choses
comme ça donc là tout de suite on est
noyé on est perdu on a eu aussi beaucoup
de difficultés d'ordre alimentaire et je
pense que les médias se sont fait le
relais de dire que les enfants qui
restent à la maison ils ont pu la
cantine ça coûte très cher va faire les
courses par la queue dans les magasins
etc etc
ça a été assez compliqué notamment pour
les gens qui ne sont pas véhiculés et
puis après ben c'est l'organisation
générale il n'y a plus vraiment de flou
autres les obligations l'extérieur
l'intérieur
le fait d'être vraiment coincé et puis
de devoir supporter les enfants qui
avaient envie de bouger et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas forcément le faire par
rapport à d'habitude autour du
confinement on a eu beaucoup de parents
qui voulaient un peu parlé ne serait-ce
que de leur isolement de leurs
difficultés à gérer leurs enfants donc
se sentir encore un peu plus je dirais
encore un peu moins à la hauteur
après que d'habitude quand on est isolé
on avait mis en place un moment donné un
apéro visio pour pouvoir justement se
connecter entre les adhérents de
réveille toi
tous les vendredis en visio pour pouvoir
parler sa durée 1h 2h 3h ça descendait
des sujets et ça faisait beaucoup de
bien donc on a surtout beaucoup les gens
au téléphone parce qu'on pouvait
effectivement plus réunir pas d'accès
aux salles pas possibilité de se réunir
à plus de trois ou quatre ou cinq
voilà tout ça c'était pour tout le monde
pareil pourquoi il ça a été assez ça a
été assez dur en tout cas de maintenir
le lien parce qu'il était finalement
permanent et ça va au delà de d'une
journée classique de ce qu'on fait
d'habitude